There are some very interesting developments
in wenty twenty democratic polling.
I know by now that merely reporting on polling
loses me subscribers and makes a lot of people
very angry.
But there are new polls that are just too
interesting not to talk about.
Now the highlights are, there's wo sets of
highlights.
Okay?
I'm just the messenger here.
I didn't do the polls in wo recent national
polls.
lizabeth Warren has taken the lead ahead of
Joe Biden nationally.
Okay?
In ne recent poll, ndrew yang is in ourth
place polling ight percent in that ne particular
poll.
So let's discuss, don't kill the messenger.
I didn't do the polls, I'm just reporting
on them.
So let's start with the national polls.
There are wo recent national polls, ne from
Quinnipiac and the other from the economist
lizabeth Warren has taken the lead nationally
in both of these polls with wenty seven percent
support.
Bernie Sanders is that ixteen percent in both
of them.
Joe Biden at wenty five percent in ne poll
at wenty six percent in the other.
So these are effectively statistical ties
with Joe Biden.
Then we get to this ndrew yang poll, the latest
Emerson poll, which has ndrew yang at ight
percent nationally.
So the immediate question is, is ndrew yang
really polling at ight percent nationally?
Now I find it very hard to imagine that that's
the case.
I know that the yang gangers will, uh, absolutely
destroy me for saying this, but in every other
poll, ndrew yang is at wo to hree percent.
Uh, if he gets another couple of polls that
say ndrew yang at ix ndrew yang at even, I
will have to rethink my analysis.
But I don't believe that ndrew yang is actually
pulling ight percent nationally.
I don't believe if you hold a, if you held
every primary today, I don't believe ndrew
yang ends up with ight percent of the votes
in the democratic primary.
Now, what is most jarring here is the Bernie
decline.
Bernie Sanders was polling anywhere from low
to mid twenties about a month ago and he now
other than the Emerson poll, which also has
yang at ight percent which raises some questions
just about every recent poll has Bernie between
ourteen and ineteen percent now to be clear,
I don't like this.
Okay, Bernie's the most progressive candidate
followed by lizabeth Warren.
I wish Bernie Sanders was doing better, but
if you look at the state numbers, they also
aren't looking that great for Bernie and it
makes me think that there's probably at least
some truth to the Bernie decline.
If you look at owa, the latest poll has Bernie
well down in hird place with only leven percent
if you look at ew Hampshire, which is the
econd primary on the schedule a Bernie is
also down in hird place with welve percent
if you look at evada, the hird primary Bernie
is down in hird place with ourteen percent
and then if you go to outh Carolina, which
is the ourth primary before we get to a bunch
of them on the same day, Bernie is still in
econd place, but that's a month old poll with
relatively stale data when Bernie was in econd
place in more of these polls.
So I want Bernie to do well, but if Bernie
can't win at least ne of those irst our primaries,
I see a difficult path for Bernie Sanders
to the nomination.
Let me know what you think and honestly guys
at this point, just talk to me about what
you think is going on here.
Don't smear me.
Don't say I'm a shill for this person or that
person.
These are not endorsements of any particular
candidate.
I've made it clear, I believe Bernie is the
most progressive candidate followed by lizabeth
Warren.
I'm not going to smear either of them.
I would be delighted to see either of them
as presidents of the nited States in the sense
that they both would be the most progressive
president in the nited States in the modern
political era.
This, this is what the data says.
And at a certain point, um, we're going to
have to just deal with the data and stop the
smears and stop the ancillary stuff.
So I do want to hear from you.
Let me know what you think.